hi guys so they have me here playing
this game always spinning a wheel here
I'm gonna be crazy in a couple years
last thing I looked up on my Google
search won't LaSalle it'll embarrassing
but a Japanese monkey baby doll my
cousin recently gave birth to a
beautiful baby boy
he also kinda reminded me like a little
Japanese monkey baby doll I built up an
image to show her and I mean I think
they're really cute I'm not gonna fit it
that hard this time Oh your mom hello I
kind of signed you up to come with me
and be on the show to do a cooking
segment with them next week this is a
brain you were supposed to call me a
[ __ ] like how you normally do you're
not being yourself right now okay I love
you I love you today that's a mom all
right I mean this is something I do on
every day on the Reg so like
famous Tector hmm
Kien I mean that's my show does that
count
oh and JLo that was this morning can't
have lunch today sorry let's try
anything next week she's always trying
to hit me on Oh Leo time is he here do a
little say swap here my best friend
really nailed that face wall